[Musique]
avec l'été arrive aussi lé fond de
saison des salles culturelles du
territoire mais avant de tomber le
rideau certaines vous attendent pour
découvrir artistes et oeuvres dont soir
mélanie poquet savent pour votre coup de
coeur de la semaine votre choix s'est
porté sur trois rendez vous et oui du
théâtre du cirque et du théâtre trois
hommes à noter dans vos agendas le
premier rendez vous c'est une création
et les signer aurore et 20 metteur en
scène les artistes associés à la ferme
de bel ébat de guyancourt elle s'est
intéressée à une loterie sangle aise à
fra ben l'une des toutes premières
dramaturge professionnelles européennes
et la pièce s'appelle une heureuse
occasion et sur scène la troupe de
théâtre amateur de la femme de vélib et
l'ensemble de musique ancienne de
l'économie si pâle pour en savoir plus
rendez vous samedi 29 juin à 20h30 un
port royal des champs c'est une oeuvre
assez original que vous nous présentez
les mousquetaires passe en mode elle
série à l'origine de l'idée le collectif
49 9 700 ha les trois premières saisons
de la série sont à découvrir ce week-end
à port royal des champs on y retrouve
tous les personnages alexandre dumas
milady athos porthos ou encore aramis
mais les auteurs ont choisi de repartir
aux origines de l'oeuvre des personnages
elle s'intéresse notamment à la violence
d'état chaotique et sanglant deux
représentations sont prévues les 29 et
30 juin à 14 heures et à noter cet
important 6 heures de spectacle prévu
avec entracte pour le dernier
rendez-vous mélanie direction la mairie
that he a pour un voyage dans les
souvenirs et la nostalgie à celles que
l'on peut trouver dans le grenier d'une
maison dans ce grenier du collectif
entre nous trois mâts chinois vieux
tourne-disque et des canapés une
garde-robe des souvenirs qu'il faut
trier et en triant se remémore un peu de
tout regarder
[Musique]
alors pour découvrir les souvenirs que
ce grenier conserve direction la merise
de traput juillet prochain merci mélanie
on vous retrouve comme d'habitude après
ce journal dans le 7-8 culture plus